cansados pero a salvo los primeros
civiles ucranianos llegan a favor y ya
ha logrado salir de la asediada mariupol
donde las tropas rusas están
bombardeando día y noche el último
bastión de resistencia ucraniana en la
planta siderúrgica de asustar allí están
refugiados miles de civiles y cientos de
soldados
toma la situación es muy mala nuestra
casa ya no tenemos casa ya no tenemos
ciudad salimos el sábado llegamos a
basílica pero no pudimos salir porque
había combates activos reto traspasar el
país
gt o decir queríamos la paz lo único en
lo que podía pensar era en que mis hijos
estuvieran a salvo no sólo mis hijos
todos los niños
nosotros
viajaron solos desde la ciudad portuaria
aunque los combates les impidieron
llegar hasta los convoyes humanitarios
de naciones unidas y cruz roja
no los he podido ver porque nuestra
ciudad está dividida entre la orilla
izquierda y la derecha la orilla
izquierda estaba totalmente bloqueada no
podíamos llegar a estos autobuses
simplemente no podíamos
la alcaldía de mariupol informó que las
evacuaciones pese a los retrasos y
dificultades continúan mientras que el
ministerio de defensa ruso dijo que en
los últimos dos días 126 personas habían
abandonado mariupol en los autobuses
humanitarios pero miles de personas
siguen atrapadas entre la ruina la
comida escasea a medida que pasan los
días
los soldados vinieron y escoltaron a las
primeras 11 personas fueron las que
estaban gravemente enfermas tenían asma
o necesitaban insulina y también a tres
de nosotros al azar más de 40 personas
incluidos niños pequeños quedaron allí
este lunes naciones unidas denunció que
los civiles fallecidos durante los 62
días de invasión del kremlin a ucrania
superarían los 3.000 la mayoría
asesinados por ataques aéreos y con
misiles rusos como los que asolan
mariupol